[موسيقى]
يحكى ان انديرا غاندي سالت والدها الزعيم
جواهر لال دهره عما تخربه الحروب في
المجتمعات فرد عليها ينهار الاقتصاد وماذا
بعد انهيار الاقتصاد اضافت ليجيب تنهار
الاخلاق
وماذا سنشاهد لو انهارت الاخلاق في الناس
يوالدي فقال لها وما الذي يبقيك في بلد
انهارت اخلاقه يا انديرا
يستطيع الانسان ان يتكيف مع النقص في
الاموال والثمرات وحتى في الانفس لكنه ان
كان سويا يابى التعايش مع مجتمع تصبح فيه
السفاله عرفا
والكرامه ضائعه
الى العناوين
سفير اسرائيل يعود الى المغرب وسفير
الجزائر يعود الى فرنسا
الامارات تفرج عن مهربه مخدرات اسرائيليه
محكومه بالاعدام والبحرين توثق علاقاتها
مع تل ابيب
هل ينهي نتنياهو دوله الاحتلال الرئيس
الاسرائيلي لا يستبعد
توقيتان في لبنان واحد للمسلمين واخر
للمسيحيين وبسيل لن نمشي على توقيت
المتخلفين
السيسي يفتتح مسجد مصر الكبير وخالد
الجندي بناء مصنع افضل من بناء عشرين الف
مسجد
صحيفه
عاجز ومتقاعد في سن الخامسه والاربعين
محمد عبده يدلكم على الطريقه التي تتاكدون
بها ما اذا كنتم تتقون الله
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في زمن الفراق والمقاطعه بين حكومتي
الجزائر والمغرب وليس بين الشعبين
الشقيقين يعود سفير الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى الرباط بحسب الاعلام العبري ونقلا عن
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه يعود الاستئناف
مهامه في الرباط بعد اغلاق التحقيق معه في
شبهات تحرش جنسي وفساد داخل المغرب على
الجهه المقابله افاد الدوائر الرئاستين
الجزائريه والفرنسيه بان سفير الجزائر لدى
فرنسا سيعود الى باريس في اشاره الى
انتهاء اخر ازمه بين البلدين تعود الى
فبراير الماضي على خلفيه تهريب فرنسا
الناشطه الجزائريه المعارضه والمحكومه
قضائيا اميره بوراوي الى تونس ومنها
من الرئيس قيس سعيد الى فرنسا سفير
الجزائر لدى فرنسا سيعود الى باريس خلال
الايام المقبله وبذلك يطبل الرئيس الفرنسي
ونظيره الجزائري صفحه الازمه الدبلوماسيه
بين البلدين ملف عالق بين الامارات
واسرائيل تم حله هذا الاسبوع ايضا
فلمناسبه شهر رمضان المبارك الذي اكرم
الله فيه المسلمين بكل خير افرجت الامارات
عن مهربه مخدرات اسرائيليه محكوم عليها
قضائيا بالاعدام بعد نحو عام ادانتها
بالاعدام افرجت السلطات الاماراتيه يوم
امس عن الشابه في داء كيوان من مدينه حيفا
وذلك بعد صدور قرار بالعفو عنها في اعقاب
توجه رئيس الدوله
بطلب لرئيس الاماراتي الشيخ محمد بن زايد
الذي اصدر قرار العفو بمناسبه شهر رمضان
المبارك لكن في نفس الوقت ادانت ابوظبي
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي في تصريحاته
العدائيه للفلسطينيين والعرب ادانه دوله
الامارات تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه يتسائيل والتي ينكر فيها وجود
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيقه كما دانت
استخدامه خريطه لاسرائيل تضم حدودا من
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله عندما تستنكر الامارات
سلوكيات اسرائيل فهذا يعني ربطا واستنتاجا
وتاكيدا ان اسرائيل في هذه اللحظه مدانه
من قبل كل الدول العربيه والاسلاميه ودول
عدم الانحياز وحتى السلفادور الا البحرين
علاقاتها تتقدم مع اسرائيل وصل وفد من
رجال الاعمال العربي في اسرائيل الى
البحرين في محاوله لتعزيز العلاقات
والحوار بين الجانبين على فخور جدا
الاجينا الاخوان في البحرين المتفاجئ جدا
اشكر رئيس الحكومه ببنتينيو عليه السلام
اسرائيل المتراميه العلاقات في المنطقه
العربيه لا تستطيع الان تنظيم علاقات
الجماعات السياسيه فيما بينها والخطر
القائم الذي يهددها بالزوال تحذر منه
نخبها من رئيسها
الى وزراء ونواب وصولا الى المهرجين
والمحللين حيث طلب احدهم ساخرا مساعده
بشار الاسد في قمع المتظاهرين وفي سياق
الاحتجاجات المستمره على مضي نتنياهو في
قراره بتعديل قوانين السلطه القضائيه حوصر
في منزله بجموع المتظاهرين الذين يرفضون
تحكم السياسيين بالسلطه القضائيه
[تصفيق]
انا هنا اليوم لانني قلقه بشان مستقبلي مع
وجود هؤلاء المسؤولين بعد سيطره مصطلحات
الحرب الاهليه وسفك الدماء على لغه
السياسيين الاسرائيليين يطرق التفكك ابواب
الجيش والشرطه ووزير الدفاع يطلق تحذيرا
عاجلا فيقيله نتنياهو من منصبه بسبب
تصريحاته فتوقفوا عن كره نتنياهوب هل
يومين بس عسى ان يكون مخلصا لكم من
الاحتلال بعد ان عجزت نجوم اكتاف
جنرالاتكم عن مس شعره منه بل انسحبت الى
قيادتي الجيش الاسرائيلي والشباك اللتين
حذرتا بحسب خبراء من انعكاس تفكك المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على الجيش وكفاءته ومن ان
الدمج بين تهديدات الامنيه والوضع
الاجتماعي قد يوصل اسرائيل الى وضع خطر
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي يخضع لمحاكمات فساد
ينفيها يمضي قدما في مشروعه وليكتمل تقليد
نتنياهو من هذا بعض انظمتنا الخشبيه تتهم
اسرته والمقربون منه الاداره الامريكيه
بشن حرب كونيه من اجل اقصائه اعاد نجل
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
نقلت عن محام وصحفي امريكي ادعى ان وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه تحاول عزل اداره
نتنياهو وفق صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت فقد قال
مسؤول سياسي كبير مرافق لنتنياهو في
زيارته الى لندن يوم الجمعه ان ادارتين
امريكيتين حاولت بالفعل عزل نتنياهو عن
السلطان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رغم المعاناه التي ولدت فيها اجيال وما
تزال الا ان كل نشاط مدني في فلسطين هو
ايضا فعل مقاومه زينه رمضان لا تغيب
واحتفالات المسلمين بالشهر الكريم لا يغيب
عنها رجال الدين المسيحيون تتزين الشوارع
بفوانيس ومصابيح ابتهاجا باستقبال شهر
الصيام تعكس مدى التنوع الثقافي الذي يجمع
الفلسطينيين بمختلف اطيافهم
[موسيقى]
وللعام الحادي عشر على التوالي يواصل
الشاب المسيحي خليل كوع من مدينه نابلس
مبادره مايو تمر توزع قبيل مدفع الافطار
على العابرين انا شاب عادي مواطن من نابلس
مسيحي
على حسابنا يعني بعدين
افتح المجال الكل يتبرع بخلص ما في ناس
كتير بتبرعوا في مقابل هذا العيش الوطني
في فلسطين وجد السياسيون اللبنانيون
اصطفافا طائفيا جديدا كاد ان يتحول الى
اشتباك بين المسلمين سنه وشيعه من جهه
والمسيحيين من جهه اخرى لولا تدخل الدروز
لفض الاشتباك
الخلاف كان على تقديم الساعه وتاخيرها
بالتوقيت الصيفي لاجل شهر رمضان علما ان
المسلمين في لبنان والمسيحيين يريدون ساعه
كهرباء اضافيه واقلبوا الساعه الى توقيت
استراليا ان رغبتم بس
اولادنا شو بدنا نكتب بالتاريخ اذا كان
الهدف من قرار الرئيسين نبيه بري ونجيب
ميقاتي الابقاء على التوقيت الشتوي حتى
نهايه رمضان هذا القرار الذي تم التراجع
عنه لاحقا اذا كان هدفه ماء اراحه
المسلمين في توقيت ثابت لصيامهم فكان من
الاولى عليهما تخصيص يوم الجمعه يوم عطله
رسميه بدل السبت فلا يوجد يهود في لبنان
على علمنا بل توجد عشرات الاف العائلات
المسيحيه والمسلمه تعيش على التحويلات
الماليه التي تصلها من مصارف الخليج او من
ايران وهذه المصارف تقفل يوم الجمعه لان
يوم الجمعه في الخليج وفي ايران هو يوم
عطله الى دور الفتوى توجهت هيئه العلماء
المسلمين للاعتصام بدلا من مجلس النواب
لدعم موقف مفتي الجمهوريه وايصال صوتهم
المطالب باعتبار يوم الجمعه عطله اسبوعيه
معتبرين انه يحق للمسلمين بنهار عطله
برمزيه دينيه اسوه بنهار الاحد الذي عدته
الهيئه خاصا بالمسيحيين مطالبتنا ان
يبقى وهكذا اصبح للبنان توقيتان لساعات
معدوده فنظريا قدم المسيحيون الساعه
والمسلمون تركوها كما هي لكن عمليا كلهم
تقدمت ساعتهم الكترونيا في هواتفهم على
توقيت المطار نحن قليله انت هلا
128 يعني انت مقدم هي اقدم
ببلد واحد صار فيتو وايتام اخواتنا
المسيحيين قربوا الساعه لقدام ساعه
اخواتنا المسلمين ما التزموا بالقرار خلوا
الساعه مثل ما هي يعني انا هلا بمنطقه
جونيه اللي هي تعد منطقه مسيحيه نازل
باتجاه الضاحيه الجنوبيه ماشي الساعه خمسه
بعد الظهر بوصل لتحت الساعه 4:00 بعد
الظهر كيف بس الله والمسيحيين والمسلمين
بلبنان بيعرفوا
بلد لا مش بلد هيقرب
[موسيقى]
مجموعين كل القيادات المسيحيه تقريبا رفضت
القرار لكن جبران باسيل اتهم هذه المره
باهانه المسلمين في لبنان وفي خارج لبنان
عندما قال سنمشي على توقيت المتطورين وليس
على توقيت المتخلفين فمن هم المتطورون ومن
هم المتخلفون في حسابات جبران الخليج
وكثير من الدول العربيه وحتى روسيا والصين
وفوقهم ايران راعيه المقاومه الاسلاميه
لحزب الله التي يهوى جبران باسير جمعه
خرطوس غنائمها لا يقدمون الساعه على
الايقاع الغربي
هؤلاء يتهمهم باسيل بانهم متخلفون علما ان
القرار نفسه بعدم تقديم الساعه مراعاه
لشهر رمضان سبق ان اتخذه زعيمه ميشال عون
عندما تراس حكومه عسكريه متمرده على
الحكومه المعترف بها دوليا اثناء الحرب
فهل كان ميشال عون متخلفا في حينه ولم يعد
الان كذلك
انه نحن بنمشي على توقيتنا وعلى الوقت
العالمي بنمشي على وقت المتطورين
المتقدمين مش على وقت المتخلفين
والراجعيين فنلندا اسعدوا بلد في العالم
وفق التصنيف الدولي ولسنه السادسه على
التوالي طالبت اوروبا بعدم تقديم الساعه
او تاخيرها فهل فنلندا متخلفه يا جبران
طيب اذا كانت الولايات المتحده هي
المتحضره عند باسيل فامريكا اتهمته
بالفساد المالي وفرضت عليه عقوبات اما
الاعلام المتحضر في امريكا فيتهب جبران
باسيل بهدر نصف دين لبنان على الكهرباء
الذي تولى شخصيا وحزبه وزارتها لسنين
طويله مع التذكير بان الرئيس الامريكي
جورج وسونطون كان اول من فكر بتقديم
الساعه صيف للاستفاده من ضوء الشمس المبكر
في الصيف وتوفير ساعه الكهرباء جبران
المتحضر وفر على اللبنانيين كل ساعات
الكهرباء ما عادت موجوده فماذا يفيد
المواطن ان يستيقظ باكرا في جهنم الارض
وفق استشراف الرئيس السابق ميشال عون نحن
لوين رايحين طبعا اجهلنا رغم كل ما تقدم
لا يرى بهيج ان جبران باسيل طائفي فهو
استطاع ان يقسم المسيحيين بين عملاء
اسرائيليين ومجرمين كسمير جعجع والقوات
اللبنانيه
وغشاشين وفاسدين كحزب الكتائب ولا قيمه
لهم كزعيم المرض سليمان فرنجيه واللصوص
اجرام مالي كحاكم المصرفي المركزي رياض
سلامه ودائما بحسب اتهامات باسيل وهو لم
يوفر ايضا البطريركيه المارونيه
والمواصفات التي تضعها لرئيس الجمهوريه
المقبول من هجماته ولم يوفر ايضا قائد
الجيش اللبناني العماد جوزيف عون فشكك
بامانته وبذمته الماليه كذلك استطاع جبران
باسيل اي يحقق ما عجز المسلمون عن تحقيقه
فوحدهم سنه وشيعه عليه فكيف يكون بسير
طائفيا بالله عليكم
[موسيقى]
افتتح المسلمون في احدى قرى اوغندا مسجدا
بني بوسائل ومواد بسيطه حيث شيده المصلون
بانفسهم بمتيسر لهم من المال القليل الذي
جمعوه ورفع الاذان لاول مره في هذه القريه
النائيه
[موسيقى]
حمد رسول الله
المساجد ذات الكلفه البسيطه يقبلها الله
تعالى لكن ذلك لا يمنع من ان يبني
المسلمون مساجد كبيره عبر التاريخ تشكل
علامات فارقه في فن العماره الاسلاميه
الرئيس السيسي افتتح مسجد مصر الكبير
بكلفه سته وعشرين مليون دولار اثارت جدلا
لكن اخرين يرون ان اثر بناء هذا المسجد لا
يقاس بالمال الذي انفق عليه للاسف خالد
الجندي ما غيره ورغم انه شيخ على قوله كان
واحدا من الذين انتقدوا بناء المساجد
الاسبوع الماضي فتح الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ما يوصف بانه اكبر مسجد في
افريقيا واحد اكبر مساجد العالم يحمل اسم
مسجد مصر وانتقد البعض عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او جهه انفاق الحكومه المصريه
فافتتاح مصنع اسمده ازوتيه اهم بكثير من
البناء عشرين الف مسجد وكيلو لجنه حقوق
الانسان في مجلس النواب المصري ايمن ابو
العلا بحاجه ماسه الى دخول السجن كي يتوقف
عن حسد المسجونين في سجون مصر الجديده
بسبب الرفاهيه التي يعيشونها غرفه
المراقبه الالكترونيه اللي موجوده
والمستشفى اللي موجوده انا اتحدى اي
مستشفى خارجي يعني انا بحسب مستشفى 380
ولا احسن مستشفى قطاع خاص فيك يا مصر
بالظبط
في المتفرقات العربيه ايضا وللمره الستين
يؤكد قائد الجيش السوداني الحاكم عبد
الفتاح البرهان انه لا يريد خلط العسكري
بالسياسه بل يريد قيام حكم ديمقراطي في
البلاد
علما ان تحقيق هذا الامر هين جدا اذا كان
البرهان ومن معه زاهدين فعلا في السلطه
نريد ان نبني قوات مسلحه قوات ملتزمه
بالمعايير التي
ترتضيها الانظمه الديمقراطيه مصاعد حفتر
تنافس في الاسواق ماركه جديده في ليبيا
بعدما وعد الجنرال المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
مناصريه في حي المشير الجديد في بنغازي
وعدهم بتركيب مصعد لكل بنايه من حسابه
الخاص فلا نعلم صدقا ما هو عمل حفتر في
الحياه حتى يكون ثريا
مواقع نشرت الفيديو مرفقا بمقطع مسرحي
لمحمد صبحي
الحق يتقال شعبنا جميل يتسرق ويسقف
الحقيقه
الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون ينتقل من
مرحله العزله الى العجز والتقاعد في سن
الخامسه والاربعين بحسب صحيفه لوبيوان
فرنسيه ماكرون الذي يعيش ازمه في كل مكان
بالعالم اصبحت ساعه يده تشكل له ازمه ايضا
بعدما نزعها اثناء مقابله على الهواء فظن
المتابعون انه تذكر ان يخفيها من الصوره
نظرا لسعرها الفاحش فاضطر
للتوضيح وانتشر مقطع لماكرون وهو يخلع
ساعته خلال المقابله واعتبر عدد من رواد
مواقع التواصل ان الرئيس الاغنياء حسب
وصفهم نزع ساعه باهظه ثمن التي اشتراها من
الرواتب التقاعديه للفرنسيين وقدر بعضهم
ثمنها بنحو 80 الف يورو اما الاليزي فقد
استنكر الترويج للاخبار الكاذبه
واكد ان الرئيس خلع ساعته بعد ان ضرب
معصمه على الطاوله واحدث ضوضاء خلال البث
المباشر تحت عنوان حمزه يوسف اول مسلم
يتولى منصب الرئيس وزراء اسكتلندا نشرت
مونت كارلو الدوليه خبرا انتخاب البرلمان
الاسكتلندي يوسف ذي الاصول الباكستانيه
والمتزوج من فلسطينيه رئيسا لحكومه
المقاطعه البريطانيه التي تطمح للاستقلال
عن لندن لكن قبل ان يتحمس البعض للخبر نود
ان نطلعكم على مقطع من مقابله مع حمزه
يوسف لا يؤيد فيها زواج المثليين فحسب بل
يعتبروا انه لا يقل شانا عن الزواج
التقليدي ولا يعتبره خطيئه
ايضا
في اسم تحالف الاحزاب الذي رشحه
الانتخابات الرئاسه الجمهوريه هذا ولم
ينتخب بعد فماذا سيفعل بهم لو صار رئيسا
جمر اتفاقنا
اخيرا وفي هذا الشهر الفضيل كل امنيه
الصائم القائم ايامنا عليه الله تعالى
بالقبول وان يكون عنده من المتقين
اليكم طريقه جديده لاكتشاف ما اذا كنتم
اتقياء او غير ذلك اذا كنتم تحبون المطرب
محمد عبده فانتم تتقون الله ومن لا يتق
الله لا يحب المطرب محمد عبده يقول عبده
بنفسه ومذيع قناه روتانا السعوديه يذكر
ابو نوره
بتاريخه في التصريحات الاشكاليه لكن
للامانه صوت محمد عبده جميل في الغناء ما
قبلت احد يتقي الله الا يحب محمد عبده
من لا يتق الله محمد عبده يعني ابو نوره
اشتهرت انت بانه التصاريح الخارج عن
السياق تراها قديمه يعني يمكن من قبل ما
ولد
[موسيقى]
ختاما وجد الى جانبه على مقعد الطائره
سيده عجوز بدت عليها علامات البساطه لما
قاموا بتقديم وجبات الطعام بدات العجوز
اكلها بالحلوى البيضاء وضعتها في قطعه خبز
ورشت عليها الزيت ظنا منها انها قطعه جبن
بيضاء ولما اكتشفت ذلك من الطعم شعرت
باحراج شديد وبالخجل من الرجل الذي
بجانبها
فتظاهر الاخير بانه لم يرى ما حصل وبعد
ثوان قليله كرر ما فعلته السيده بقطعه
حلوى مع الخبز والزيت فنظرت اليه وابتسمت
ليسالها جار الرضا لماذا لم تخبريني يا
امي بانها حلوى لقد ظننتها جبنه فردت
المراه وانا ايضا ظننتها كذلك
الموقف النبيل لا يكلف صاحبه الكثير لكنه
يجعله كبيرا وقليل من الناس كبير الى
اللقاء
ابشر ابشر بعون الناس
[موسيقى]
وبخيرهم ابشر